Of that bill and make it last
so just a heads up there.
As we begin the hour. I want to
bring you.
On our
vice president. Sometimes it's
unclear where she is at any
given time which actually let
us to create.
A brief segment, a little left
theme song a bus for the vice
president.
>> Ahead over She's actually.
>> an official government trip.
There was a clip of
her today. In France speaking
with.
Some people I guess at some
sort of scientific facility and
it sounds like she starts to
almost put on a little bit of a
French accent. Which was a
>> We're expected to defend the
flag.
Even when the first time we
roll it out there may be some
glitches and it's time to re
evaluate and then.
>> it again.
Today is zip plan.
>> Leave it there for one more
which will have a re a long
cigarette.
>> Zip plan.
>> A walking talking embodiment
of veep. Who happens to be
actually the veep.
And this is actually perhaps a
bit of an achievement. She is
in Europe, she is in French
remember this back in June.
She was asked about why she had
not gone to the border.
As the border crisis is are
doing a great job obviously
and part of her very strange
answer to that question with
NBC News was this cut 20 you
have any plans.
>> To visit the border, but at
some point you know it. We're
going to the border we've been
to the border.
So this whole this whole this
whole thing about the board
we've been to the border.
We've been to the board you
haven't done before. I and I
haven't been to Europe and I
felt night out
understand the point that
you're making I'm not
discounting the importance of
the border.
>> That was so strange
that was so awkward at the time
of course we've got the laugh
we've got to laugh and they're
at her a little joke about
having not gone to Europe so
we've been to the border said
no you haven't played well.
So that must be very exciting
for her.
On Jimmy Kimmel show last night
that say if you're unfamiliar
Jimmy Kimmel is a Democratic
strategist and part time
comedian and he's got a show on
one of the networks that loses
to Greg gutfeld every night
Garfield on cable Kimmel on
broadcast and he loses every
night Greg gutfeld which is
fun. Jimmy Kimmel's a sort just
sleazy.
At cause a comedian guy who
gets a lot of his talking
points literally written for
him by Chuck Schumer that was
actually revealed. We'll come
out and do some of his little
indignant monologues about
Republicans. He gets his quote
UNQUOTE facts from Chuck
Schumer's office. So he's a
Democratic strategist also a
self-appointed pope. You know
he he wants everyone to take
his moral decrees very
seriously. As he should I mean
he made
his career. As a guy who sat
around drinking beer as women
jumped on trampoline try this
is this is someone who can
absolutely preach from on high
to all of us. So this
Democratic strategist and
part-time comedian had some
thoughts about kamala Harris.
It's been. Not a great couple
of weeks on polling
for president Biden or for vice
president Harris we talk about
how Harris was that
just about as unpopular as
Biden slightly less popular as
a matter of fact in Suffolk USA
Today poll.
And Jimmy Kimmel was upset
about this a fellow Democrat,
you know is under attack not
not garnering rave reviews from
the American people so Kimmel
decided that obviously the
problem is the American people
cut 14 presence really.
>> It has approval rating of
20%
with his. Les snow says because
he basically has nothing to do
I mean it's like. Criticizing a
backup quarterback Tom
Brady's okay. I don't love the
way Blaine Gabbert has legs
folded
20% even lower than the
30% cool through the 16 2008
after he saw the guy in the
things.
I think the Steelers getting at
least 10%
of those polled approved of
dictating because
I think you know why com was
ratings are like this I'd such
as the race is what it is.
>> Besides sexism and racism.
The obvious reasons why her
approval rating is so low.
Well, you know she is at
negative 23. In that poll under
water by 23 points Biden is
statistically the same.
Underwater by 21 points.
Last time I checked Joe Biden
is of fairy white Matt.
Now is it sexism and racism
that explains his poor approval
rating was at only for his
similarly unpopular vice
president who has put in charge
of some big things like the
border which is a disaster, I
know he's saying the vice
president doesn't do anything
maybe that's part of the
problem. She's tasked with
things and then doesn't do them
or doesn't do them. Well.
So it's sexism
and racism and explains why
Harris
is unpopular. But fill in the
blank for wide Biden's on
popular I'm sure it's probably
more of the same. That is they
see sexism and racism built in
excuse always and forever
couldn't possibly be the
failures of the administration.
And the leaders of that
administration and the
2 most high ranking government
officials in the entire United
States of America. That's it's
a big difficult fought for
Jimmy. So he's got his
answer there. It's sexism and
racism. I actually. Do you have
a thought though.
Kind of like a follow-up
question for Jimbo here
which is why is it
that kamala Harris when she was
running for president member
she called Joe Biden a racist.
During that campaign.
She was running for president
she wanted his job not her
current job. She was such a
bad candidate. For president.
That she didn't even survive
the candidates, he did not even
survive to Iowa. She dropped
out before a single primary or
caucus, voter, even showed up.
And I know this might be
difficult for Jimmy to remember
if he even knows this stuff
maybe get a little quick
refresher tutorial from Chuck
Schumer. But that was a
Democratic primary. That was
all his team, their side.
And by his team, I mean you
know the Democrats the side.
You know what that he embodied
for example when he lost to Ted
Cruz in a one on one basketball
game something he should never
live down hilarious. It was his
team
his party, the enlightened non
racist massage nests supposedly
in their party who were so
unimpressed by kamala Harris
that they.
Rejected her forcefully enough
in the polls that she didn't
even bother to come to Iowa to
get humiliated
and lose badly by her own
side's voters, maybe that's
also sexism and racism Jimmy I
don't know. But the proof is in
the pudding. In the Democratic
primary.
So my theory is maybe her
approval rating tied to the
flailing president. Tied to the
failing administration. In
which she is a major part.
Poor execution. And
poor results. On one of the
most high-profile items in her
portfolio.
And tied to the fact
that she is an insufferable
phony and it's so obvious.
Perhaps Jimmy Kimmel has a sort
of knee jerk
understandable defensiveness
when it comes to fellow
insufferable phonies that could
be part of it.
It could just be that he
sympathies or has a soft spot.
4 people like kamala Harris who
will literally laugh